hello and welcome to what might be the
end of the Archer and June Saga I am
moving on to sort of another project and
I'm Gonna Leave This one somewhat as it
is
not necessarily saying I'm abandoning it
or anything like that I just feel like
it's gonna be better for me to move on
to a different thing which I'll get to
shortly but I want to give just kind of
a quick overview of the project and just
kind of make a little end cap for it of
course there is a big playlist of all
these Vlogs dating back a couple years
where you can see my uh sometimes quick
seeming progress and sometimes my slow
seeming progress but such as the way
with working on your own big piece of
software that's made me something like a
game engine well this was the 0.1
version
it was titled ancient Archer I started
developing it in college when I started
a graphics course in which they taught
opengl it's about a 12-week course and
uh near the end when we're making our
own we're supposed to make our own game
for a final project I kind of got a
little sidetracked with making the
engine rather than an actual game so I
pretty much had an engine to show off
which I kind of fake made a game within
to show the class but uh yeah that's how
this all started and learn opengl was
one of the main sources for learning it
and yeah here it is so I wish there's
one big mistake I made at some point I
deleted all the history because it was
just a giant it was the history was so
giant there used to be Assets in here
and stuff those were all just in the
history but I did I used to have a bunch
of releases now I I did make a video of
this I think it's video three or four or
five the series somewhere in there that
goes over all the releases it's like the
50 minute video but if you go through
that you'll see some of the demos I made
early on with this engine and then it
became a lot more and then I got to the
point where I could start making uh
animations and got some shadows in there
and overall
it was a great learning experience and I
could have went further with it I could
have made a game or something uh it
would have been real janky but you see
we could have pieceded this kind of
stuff together there's also sound
uh yeah well
I didn't really have an exact plan for
this video other than the go over stuff
but the continuation of this project
just Archer and gin which was the 2.0
version is here and this one I hacked on
a bunch I started refactoring I did a
bunch of things I updated a lot of stuff
still the same renderer still the same
sound and it's still almost the same
engines I just started refactoring a lot
of things tried to clean it up a lot but
essentially it was still the same use
case
and I got to a point where I started
trying to work in some Dynamic shaders
and completely refactor the whole thing
I was going to use well this is kind of
where I left off I started adding an ECS
and when I started adding an ECS I got a
good ways into it when I kind of
realized something and that's where this
project switched over for me you know
I've always said I've always been a
proponent I'd work on something that you
enjoy if you really want to be a
programmer you got a program frequently
just to get used to everything just the
way it is you're gonna really struggle
if you don't program much but you know
you can figure out there's Google and
all that so but if you really want to
get good for example I know that sounds
very elitist but I think that's I'm kind
of a competitive person naturally I
don't really care what other people are
doing or that sort of thing and I don't
think you should necessarily compare to
me but it's often nice to look to each
other for inspiration
and that's kind of a better mentality I
think than being really competitive so
yeah I
I'm not really into that stuff I'm not
that social of a person despite what you
might think from watching me on YouTube
so
I tend to just one out
I don't know how to explain myself I
suppose I just I just feel like a giant
a giant uh
green person or something if I only talk
about myself trying to avoid the n-word
no not not that inward the one that
starts with Gnar you know you don't want
to say okay I'll just say it if I talk
about my
itself and my accomplishments I'm going
to sound like a narcissist you know I
don't really you know it's just a word
it's just a tag but it's overall not a
healthy mentality we want to really get
things done we have to work together
everyone's got to put their ego aside if
someone projects ego it should be
because they're very passionate about
their idea and they really want to get
their ideas across because I think
they're important not you know not
because you actually think you're all
self-important or whatever you know we
all are important so that's another
tricky part I'm gonna just turned into a
rant of Lessons Learned I'm coding a big
project and being YouTube or whatever as
a introvert that just wants to code
well comparison is the thief of Joy
that's what it comes down to
alright so this was the new version
we'll just move on to talking about this
and I left it off here I think I'm
actually gonna abandon this Branch
should I continue to work on everything
go back to main or Dev and your Dev
everything else can be most of these can
be deleted I think actually now it's
just should be just made in depth so
I'll probably do that within the month I
want to have a look over these little
branches and see if there's anything I
need to really consider because I think
I the big thing I did in this Branch was
I updated a lot of how the windowing
system was in there and I might want to
keep some of that because I don't want
to have to refactor it again but anyway
nothing else really I don't think needs
to be kept so
what am I working on now
I'm working on a private project
it is a game I'll say that much
and I'm writing it from scratch no
engine and that's all I'm going to say
about it right now but my main goal is
to get that released
you probably saw my video from two
videos ago where I kind of expressed
that I'm I'm just uh
basically gonna go on a bit of a
sabbatical you could call it after this
month so all of November to next year
November
I'm gonna attempt to remain off pretty
much all social media the only way I
will be accessible is through a private
message and I'll be locking down a lot
of the uh just platforms
just to a more elitist fashion if you
will just a little less spam a little
more quality that's always the goal with
life
well thanks for watching I'll see you
guys next time
Matt from code Tech tutorials over and
out for the last time hopefully well not
necessarily hopefully but in theory of
this series
goodbye
[Music]